jetzt sehen wir den bundespräsidenten
und den gewählten bundeskanzler wie
heißt es bundeskanzler elektro kommen
zusammen und schloss bellevue hier gibt
es leicht die ernennungsurkunde da
schauen wir live rein
63 absatz 2 satz 2 des grundgesetzes für
die bundesrepublik deutschland herrn
olaf scholz zum bundeskanzler berlin den
8 dezember 2021
der bundespräsident und die unterschrift
herr bundeskanzler man ganz herzlichen
glückwunsch
service halten wir die glaube ich noch
mal aufgeklappt in die kamera
so in einen herzlichen dank wir sehen
uns nachher wieder
ja ja ist es olaf scholz hat die
ernennungsurkunde erhalten von
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
das schließt sich erst mal die tür von
schloss bellevue das noch mal der blick
nach innen ins schloss hinein ein kurzer
ein offizieller akt aber ein sehr
feierlicher moment